no but
we're talking like a vast amount of
artists
like you just said little chucky chucky
twist uh
chanel she now had the music the
piercing right me guns
so many people and it seemed
tiger tiger nicki drake it just seemed
like
uh being on young money could be more
too that's the crazy part
a lot more but it could be perceived to
be a gift and a curse
t street shout out my man c street
streets but like what
why do you think uh it didn't work out
for everybody
and by everybody i mean the majority of
the artists on the label
i tell people this all the time it never
works out for everybody
once you understand that it's like
and i'm looking at this picture of
charles barkley right now and he's
taking me somewhere right
i want to explain people something there
was a lot of great people
on the sixers when barclay came
a lot of great people uh
on the lakers when kobe came i
always tell people i always tell people
i know what it feels like to be eddie
jones
hmm i know what it feels like to be
eddie jones not saying that i'm not
nice well i'm not great but i know what
it was like to be
great and somebody comes around and they
are
undeniable you can go in the studio and
make the dopest [ __ ] you want
aubrey is undeniable i remember the
first time wayne let me hear successful
i was like whoa this [ __ ] is dope the
next time i heard it wayne had a
different verse
i said why you got a different version
so i sent it to drake and he said he
didn't really
he liked the verse but he didn't really
think it went with the concept of the
song i said he made you do a verse over
damn you know what i'm saying but and
but it showed me the respect
wayne had for that right yeah because he
did the same thing for me
um he did the same thing for me yeah get
it over
i respect you you know what you're right
you know what i'm saying so
that just brings me back to the whole it
was a lot of artists what happened it
was a lot of artists on
cash money there's a lot of artists on
no limit a lot of artists on death row
but i remember
snoop pot and the dog pound
not saying lady of rage or jewell or or
crook
or or you know it's not to say that it
wasn't great crook was a part of it
after like
the dark the dark years of death it's
not to say that they wasn't great but
nikki was undeniable drake was
undeniable
out of let's say if it was 10 of us
because it was all
it was like 10 10 11 of us it was a lot
to hit with three wait the way that you
hit
now some people might say mel's you're
being a little too cordial about that my
[ __ ] because you wasn't one of those
three
it's how i work sometimes keep it moving
figure it out
that wasn't my first stop on the train
it's not gonna be my last
i came there with deals already mm-hmm a
lot of people
came there that was their first time
that was their first
rodeo right right you know i'm sad and
fell off the horse and then
did all of this [ __ ] already so this
isn't new to me i know that this [ __ ]
ain't going to last forever and i feel
like a lot of people
they thought it was going to last
forever i think with tiger
he had been around he had been with gym
class heroes he had coconut milk
traveling knowing how to make this [ __ ]
work drake had already been come back
season i would almost argue that that
tiger pop despite lil wayne he did
wayne tune i love you i love you toon
all right tiger will tell you this wayne
didn't like that direction that tiger
was going in
like make it nasty rack city [ __ ]
better have my money dancing for them
dollars right
uh what was the joint he had ass so
fat needed a lap damn wasn't feeling
that because
you got to understand that's not the
vision wayne saw for him when he first
met him you tiger tiger you
know bouncy flow like kind of like some
souls of mischief type [ __ ]
you different you like a real west coast
lyrical
crafty with your words and now you going
strip club
or me they don't even really have strip
clubs where you act like that
like where this coming from it was kind
of like
when i used to first got around young
money you listen to dedication three my
boss was like
on top of each other on top of each
other even anytime i did mix tapes with
young money
my bars was on top of each other like
that and that's because wayne taught me
how to
differentiate it she ain't got a man
but she's not alone miss independent yes
she gotta own
hey i hated that verse that was the end
of my verse
wayne said now you know what i think you
should start the verse off like that
because that's more like
that's a memorable and i'm just like i
don't care
i was more into i got a [ __ ] named
keisha from around the way
she used to go to college school back in
the day he was like oh [ __ ] that's dope
that's why he just wanted me to talk
crazy all day because in his mind his
vision for me was
they already know you for talking crazy
you said big in my trouble or what
and i put a gun in your face we love you
for that
so you get a pass to do that because a
little chucky and a little twist can't
do that
they're not known for that they got to
be kids still
you know what i'm saying so he had
visions for all of us he never really
wanted all of us to be like
signed to young money he wanted us to be
young money a group and we do some
wu-tang [ __ ] and all get deals
i know this sounds like crazy this
sounds like
yeah right mills he did he never really
wanted us all to be signed
to him he wanted to give us a platform
and we go rep young money
and get deals and bags everywhere but we
still like this
[ __ ] conglomerate on some [ __ ]
because in his mind
the hot boys was all solo artists true
so like if they if birdman could put me
in the studio
with bg and juvenile i don't want to
hear y'all
say nothing about me putting y'all in
the studio a little chucking a little
twist yeah man i mean
he'll check in little twist god bless
him look there was some time that we
drop off
there was some times that we was like
tuned check this out bro
we love you man we love you but
come on man it's 5 45 a.m man it's
beeping looping for
we don't really want to do this but but
i knew that a lot of see me
i knew a lot of the [ __ ] that wayne used
to do to us was a test it was like boot
camp it's a lot of y'all i need to see
who really wanted
right you know what i'm saying i need to
see who gonna go
hard like it ain't really about who nice
you could be dead nice but you might be
lazy